okay so we are back on my code pen with
a different quote but this time we are
on the console tab of developer tools
now I'm not I don't have any examples to
show you right now console I'm not going
to spend a ton of time on console either
because it's pretty similar to how your
console runs on your computer which I've
talked about in other videos it's a good
way to get administrative messages it
also has some alerts you can build into
your code console log and your
JavaScript will put it in this chrome
console there is something really cool
that you can do whenever there is
information in the console its dot table
console dot table now there's not
anything in here right now but it if
there was any data in there it sorts it
out makes it really easy to look at
that's something that I really do like
about console so since this is loading
all of my zip lines on code pen all of
these little zip lines had console
logging messages and since they're all
being loaded in their own little windows
all of those messages are loading right
now so if we look at this one that's my
location and response for this object
it's it's all that information it's in
the console which is a really awesome
tool I especially like it when I'm
getting information from an API I want
to view everything in that API so I can
figure out what key I need to reference
later there are about a hundred
gazillion ways to use the console
effectively and just like everything
else you have to figure out what works
best for you and what you use the most I
want to stress one more time to check
out chrome dev tools let's find the
console panel this is what the page
looks like for the documentation it is
so easy to use check it out